Sal: In the last video, we
learned that if you just leave
water to itself,
it autoionizes.
So let me see.
I have molecules of water.
There's some probability, and
it's an equilibrium, that one
of the hydrogens on one of the
waters bumps off and just
joins the other one.
So you could end up with
a hydronium ion.
It's an ion because it has
an extra hydrogen.
So I'll put a plus
charge there.
And obviously, everything
you hear is
in an aqueous solution.
I could write aqueous
everywhere.
aq.
I could write aq.
It's kind of obvious.
Water is obviously an
aqueous solution.
It's obviously dissolved
in water.
And then plus a hydroxide ion.
This is the water molecule that
lost its hydrogen atom,
or its proton.
Because we know that a hydrogen
atom-- or at least a
hydrogen ion-- if you get rid of
its electron, all you have
left is a proton.
And that's also in an
aqueous solution.
And we learned that people
really care--
We learned about
the equilibrium
constant of this reaction.
And we also learned that people
really care about the
concentration of this
right here.
Of the hydronium.
And let me write this again.
And I went over this
in the last video.
But sometimes the same exact
autoionization reaction will
be written like this.
H2O, disassociating in itself,
really, into a hydrogen ion in
an aqueous solution plus a
hydroxide anion in an aqueous
solution or a negative ion.
These are the same thing, and
I write it this way because
this is actually the
state that happens.
That you don't actually have
these protons just
independently, they actually
do join onto another water
molecule and form
a hydronium ion.
But these are the same
exact concept.
But we learned in the last video
that people really care
about the concentration
of-- you could pick
one of these two.
They normally write this
one, right here.
So people really care about
the concentration of your
hydrogen ions.
And we learned in the last video
that just pure water at
25 degrees Celsius, which
is room temperature.
So let me write that.
At 25 degrees Celsius.
The concentration of your
hydrogen protons-- because
that's really what they are,
or hydrogen ions-- is 10 to
the minus 7 molars.
And then we even said, hey,
chemists, for whatever reason,
don't like dealing with
negative exponents.
So they defined the pH as equal
to the minus log base 10
of your hydrogen
concentration.
And of course, that's equal to
minus log base 10 of 10 to the
minus 7 for pure water, at 25
degrees, which is equal to 7.
Fair enough.
And you can probably imagine, if
people took the trouble of
constructing this pH thing and
saying it's the negative log,
they must really care about
what the hydrogen
concentration of water is.
And it does matter to-- in a
whole bunch of-- especially
actually biological systems--
all the time, people worry
about the pH of this or that.
And obviously I talked
in the last video
about pH-balanced cosmetics.
All sorts of bad things might
happen to your skin if the pH
of the cosmetic is different
than your skin.
I don't know if that's a fact,
but I guess that's the that's
the theory behind it.
So there's obviously things in
the world that change the
hydrogen concentration.
That change this
concentration.
So, when we learned about Le
Chatelier's Principle, we said
hey, maybe if we add more
hydrogen on this side, the
equilibrium will change and this
concentration will go up.
And so we have more hydrogen
concentration.
I guess on the other side, you
could add more hydroxide and
then you would have more OH
concentration, and maybe a
little less hydrogen
concentration.
So if you if you care about
things that are going to do
that to this reaction,
you probably want to
have a name for them.
And the name for them
is acids and bases.
And I'm sure you've heard both
of these words before.
So, let me write
them both down.
Acid and base.
Now.
Just to over-complicate your
life a little bit more, there
are actually multiple
definitions of an acid and
multiple definitions
of a base.
And they kind of become
more and more broad
in what they imply.
The definition that you're
probably going to use the
most-- the definition that I
always use in my head whenever
someone says an acid-- is
it increases hydrogen
concentration when you
place it in water.
And a base is something that
increases your hydroxide
concentration in water.
This is the definition that
you're probably going to see
in 90%-- especially in a first
year chemistry class.
And this is called the Arrhenius
acid or base.
I hope I get his
spelling right.
You should never take any
of the my spelling
words at face value.
You should look them up because
I'm clearly not a
master speller.
Arrhenius.
Arrhenius, with an H.
These are Arrhenius acid,
Arrhenius base.
Let me give you an example.
If I were to take some
hydrochloric acid-- that's
actually what it's called, but
you could say hydrogen
chloride-- in an aqueous
solution.
It actually disassociates
completely.
This is not an equilibrium
reaction.
So let me put it in
this nice-- let me
use a bolder color.
This nice one-way arrow, which
says, hey, this isn't one of
these wishy-washy reactions that
go in both directions.
This is a strong acid.
It completely disassociates in
water into-- let me put the
hydrogen in a different color.
It completely disassociates in
water into a hydrogen ion.
An aqueous solution
plus chloride.
So it's just a chloride
negative ion
in an aqueous solution.
And they just float in there.
So you could imagine if you
place hydrogen chloride in
water, you're going to increase
its overall hydrogen
concentration.
And the same exact reaction
could have been
written like this.
Just to hit the point home.
Hydrogen chloride in an
aqueous solution.
And then you can say plus
h-- let me do it
in a different color.
Plus H2O.
It's a one-way reaction.
And then you end up with, and
I think you understand.
Obviously not all 3 of them
are-- H3O, that's too dark.
H3O plus-- it donated
its hydrogen proton
to this water molecule.
And then you have plus
the chloride anion
in an aqueous solution.
And these acids that completely
disassociate-- in
future videos, we're going to
look at ones that are a little
bit more wishy-washy.
That don't completely
diaassociate.
But these acids that completely
disassociate are
called strong acids.
And strong isn't just
a nice word
that they use in chemistry.
It literally means-- when
someone says a strong acid,
something that completely
disassociates into water.
It's a one-way reaction.
And all of a strong acids-- you
could probably even guess
based on their chemical
make-up.
But hydrochloric acid
is one of them.
You also have hydrogen
bromide.
Another strong acid.
Hydrogen iodide.
You have nitric acid.
I think I showed you that
in a previous--
All of these, when you when you
put them into water, this
little h is going to pop off.
You join another water molecule,
form hydronium.
And then this molecule right
here, in these cases-- well,
in the case of chloride--
these are halogens.
But they're going to go and
form negative ions.
Whatever's left over.
Nitric acid.
Then you have sulfuric acid.
You've probably heard of that.
Very strong acid.
Sulfuric acid and then
perchloric acid.
These are the strong acids.
O4.
And these are good to know,
because if you see them on a
chemistry exam, you know that
these are going to completely
disassociate.
And remember, we keep using
this word acid.
What does acid mean?
It means that these
are strong acids.
These completely disassociate.
If you like Arrhenius's
definition of what an acid is,
they increase your hydrogen
concentration.
Because obviously when you throw
this in some water, all
of these new hydronium ions are
going to be formed, and
they're going to overall
increase your
concentration of them.
And that's why they're
called an acid.
And now if you went on the
strong base side, by
Arrhenius's definition, the base
is something that creates
hydroxide ions, or
anions in water.
If you look at the periodic
table, any of your group 1
elements, and group 1 elements
are your alkali earth metals.
Your alkali earth metals are
bonded with hydroxide.
If you put them in water,
the hydroxide pops off.
So let me just-- has to do
with lithium or sodium.
So for example, these
are strong bases.
So if I take some lithium
the hydroxide
in an aqueous solution.
This completely disassociates.
No equilibrium here.
This is a strong base.
So what's it going to
disassociate to?
Well the little hydroxide
ion is going to pop off.
That's going to be a minus.
It's in water still.
Plus a lithium ion.
Right there.
So this will always disassociate
in water.
The same thing is if
you have sodium.
Sodium's going to do
the same thing.
Sodium hydroxide in an
aqueous solution.
One-way reaction.
You produce hydroxide and
some sodium cations.
And so you imagine, when you
put these in water, this
concentration is
going to go up.
It's just like what we did in
Le Chetalier's Principal.
Where we said, oh, what if you
add some of this or some of
that to an equilibrium
reaction.
Well, how do you add it?
Well, in this case, you
can add a strong
acid or a strong base.
Now, everything I've done so
far-- this is the Arrhenius
definition-- where an acid
increases your hydrogen
concentration, a base increases
your hydroxide
concentration.
Now that is what you're going
to see 90% of the time.
But there is a slightly broader
definition out there.
And I don't know the correct--
I always say
just Bronsted, but.
If you don't have fancy fonts,
it's spelled like this.
Bronsted-Lowry acid or base.
If you if you have good fonts,
there's usually this little
cross at the o.
So I don't know.
Well, Bronsted-Lowry acid.
And all of these would also
be Bronsted-Lowry acid.
But the broadening of the
definition is an acid is a
proton donor.
And a base is a proton
acceptor.
So let's look at this definition
in the context of
everything we've just
done so far.
So if you live buy the
Bronsted-Lowry definition,
what is a proton donor here?
Well, this hydrochloric acid
is-- let me look at this
reaction right here.
This hydrochloric acid is
donating a proton to this
water molecule, right?
A hydrogen atom is
just a proton.
That's an important thing to
remember, because it had-- a
hydrogen ion.
Because if you get rid of its
electron, it has no neutron.
It's just a proton
sitting in space.
So this hydrochloric acid is
donating a proton to this
water molecule to make a
hydronium molecule, and it
gave it away.
So this is a Bronsted-Lowry
acid as well.
Just as it was an
Arrhenius acid.
Let's see the Bronsted-Lowry
version of a base.
OK.
A base is someone who--
proton acceptor.
So this guy, he had this nice
little relationship with this
hydroxide ion.
The hydroxide ion got
disassociated, and it becomes
a little bit fungible
right here.
You can kind of say hey,
this guy accepted
this positive charge.
And, you know, it's a little
bit wishy-washy here.
Because it's not like someone
gave it a proton.
You can kind of think
of it as he
actually gave away electrons.
But if you just look at
the final product.
OK, he's got a positive charge
when everything was done.
So you say OK, maybe that's
a Bronsted-Lowry base.
Now you're saying, OK well, why
did people even make the
trouble of defining a
Bronsted-Lowry base when all
of the Arrhenius acids and
bases could also be
Bronsted-Lowry.
Well that's because Arrhenius
is always--
You're always dealing
with water.
Everything's in an
aqueous solution.
But I drew an example here
of a Bronsted-Lowry base.
It doesn't have to be
an aqueous solution.
So if you have acetic
acid right here--
that's what's in vinegar.
Plus ammonia-- it doesn't have
to be in an aqueous solution--
what happens?
This hydrogen gets
donated to the
ammonia ion to make ammonium.
So this becomes positive,
this because negative.
It donated this proton.
And Arrhenius has nothing
to say for this.
Because everything he deals with
is hydronium and water.
But the Bronsted-Lowry
definition
works in the situation.
Now the broadest definition--
although they're all these
definitions, but you're going to
be 90% of the time good if
you just know the Arrhenius
definition and just know the
Bronsted-Lowry and what
I'm about to say
right now also exists.
And that's Lewis acids
and bases.
Now Lewis cares about
electrons.
Bronsted-Lowry cared
about protons.
So Lewis, instead of saying an
acid is a proton donor, Lewis
acid says it's an electron
acceptor.
And a base is an
electron donor.
Now, let's us look at in the
context of everything we've
done so far.
If this is really an
acid, it should
be an electron acceptor.
And the way you can kind of
think of it is you had
hydrochloric acid before, when
this guy gave away this atom
or this proton right there.
He kind of kept his elecron.
So he was kind of an
electron acceptor.
It's a little bit of
a grey area there.
It's not like he took an
electron from somebody else.
But this would be considered
still a Lewis acid.
And if you think about a Lewis
base, a Lewis base is what?
It's an electron donor, right?
So if you have it right
here, Lewis base
is an electron donor.
This lithium hydroxide, when it
goes into water-- There's a
couple of ways to think of it.
You can say hey, it's donating
this OH, which has these 2
extra-- this negative charge,
so it's an electron donor.
I don't lik it.
It's kind of squishy that way,
so I'm not a big fan of that
definition.
In my mind, Arrhenius makes
the most sense.
It's kind of the purist thing.
Are you creating hydronium
or not?
Or are you creating
hydroxide or not?
But just to show that the Lewis
acid base definition is
the broadest definition.
Here's a case of a Lewis
acid base reaction.
That would not be considered
either a Bronsted-Lowry or an
Arrhenius base.
Because this doesn't have
to happen in water.
And what you have here is boron
trifluoride, with a
fluoride anion.
It has a negative charge.
It has this little extra
electron here.
In this situation, this fluoride
right here, or this
fluorine anion can donate
these 2 electrons.
So let's say that this
one right here is
this one right here.
And what it does is, it donates
these 2 electrons to
this boron complex right here.
And so if it's the electron
donor, what is it?
The fluoride is the base.
So this is Lewis base.
And then the electron acceptor
is the Lewis acid.
So this right here is
the Lewis Acid.
It's good to know that these
definitions exist, and
especially so you don't get
confused in the future.
But for a first-year chemistry
class, if you know the
Arrhenius definition
really well, you'll
do very, very well.
And frankly in my mind, that's
the easiest one to
contemplate.
And that's the one that's going
to matter in most of the
reactions where you deal with
the changes in pH to water.
Because that's what all the
acids and bases do, especially
in the Arrhenius case.
Anyway, see you in the next
video and watch as we do some
math, figuring out the changes
in pH due to some acid.